wild swings in the stock market are
fueling concerns over a potential new
economic slowdown the Dow plunged more
than 550 points on Friday was partly a
response to rising trade tensions
between the US and China after the
arrest of the CFO of the Chinese tech
company Huawei it's been a decade since
the last major economic slowdown about
8.7 million Americans lost their jobs
and some of the world's biggest banks
collapsed Alex Wagner spoke to some of
the key players in the 2008 financial
crisis Alex good morning good morning we
met up with former Federal Reserve
Chairman Ben Bernanke and former
Treasury Secretary Henry Paulson Hank
Paulson and Timothy Geithner at
Delmonico's restaurant in New York's
financial district which is of course
the epicenter of the 2008 financial
crisis we discussed their HBO
documentary us-china relation and
today's economy
Victor's leaving a lot better these days
though yeah well that's a low bar to get
over there nicknamed the three amigos
the men who worked behind closed doors
to stave off another Great Depression
but ten years since the Great Recession
they addressed the personal toll the
2008 financial crisis had on them I felt
very very alone and very very
disconsolate we really felt like we were
kind of out on an island there just
having that crushing sense of
responsibility and fear the scariest
times for me were never during the day
we were too busy right we were talking
to each other they were working it'd be
waking up in the middle of the night you
had nightmares Oh their new HBO
documentary delves into what really
happened during the financial market
meltdown were a few days away from the
ATMs not working it was a crisis caused
by irresponsible mortgage lending and a
subsequent bubble burst in the housing
market Tim worked in the Treasury and
the Asia crisis
Hank was in markets for many years I was
as an academic I worked on the Great
Depression and so in a way we were
prepared and that was fortuitous and we
were complementary to each other but I
have to say it's not something that you
know you may train for war but you don't
necessarily want to be in combat I
didn't feel prepared
I think that we I think we had this the
the the constant relentless experience
over and over again of facing something
that was existential and its effects on
on people's lives without being
completely confident that you were gonna
be able to fix it fix it while some
credit them from saving the country from
a worst case scenario there are those
that felt the decision to save the
too-big-to-fail banks came at the
expense of the average American the fact
that the American public hates what we
did is not surprising because in many
ways it's not American the things that
were deeply unpopular and seem deeply
unfair were the necessary essential
thing to prevent damage it would have
been dramatically worse for the economy
if we had indulged the natural instinct
of people which is to let the thing burn
this sort of the thesis of this project
this documentary is that the
after-effects of the financial crisis
led to arise in populism was the
financial crisis a tipping point for
American populism financial crises do
tend to lead to populist reactions
sometimes and this didn't help obviously
we had a crisis we had a Great Recession
but we've had structural issues in the
United States for many many years at
least 30 or 40 years increasing
inequality hiding an ability for people
to get ahead it's an inequality that
still persists black homeownership in
America now stands at levels not seen
since the segregation era is the idea
that you live the American Dream and you
get to buy a house is that has that gone
no I don't think it's gone I think that
it was exaggerated we one of the reasons
that subprime lending got so popular it
was because it was expanding the
American Dream and that turned out to be
a mistake and the truth is that you know
homeownership is important but it isn't
the only way to build wealth it isn't
the only way to have a stable community
there's a sort of idea that buying a
home is the thing that every family
should do is some families don't need to
buy a home
some families you know I'm better off
with with rental there are other kinds
of arrangements do you think the
president and his policies are
strengthening and making the American
economy more
zillions I mean we are in a trade war
with China populism is fierce does that
concern you I would say gravely yeah you
know no no country can be stronger than
its political system and the political
system the United States today is has
lost the capacity to govern I'm for one
am relatively optimistic that what
you're going to see is the Trump
administration in China on tactical
issues come to an agreement and the
tariff war and the tariff war but even
when that happens there are going to be
significant structural issues and this
is going to be a very difficult
relationship between the US and China
for some time and that I don't attribute
that to the Trump administration there's
nothing that unites Democrats and
Republicans today like anti China
rhetoric and sentiment we need to find
common ground with China for a global
economic system to work for us to have
peace prosperity stability we don't need
another Cold War are you confident that
if the next financial crisis was armored
America's doorstep that this president
and this Congress could handle it I
don't think we have a system in place to
deal with a crisis once it happens we
have a lot of things that make it a
crisis less likely so the fire is less
likely to occur but if it if it does
occur I think we have fewer you know
fewer fire hoses than we that we had
even in ten years ago all three men say
they hope the new documentary helps
people better understand what went wrong
and the decision-making inside the Obama
and Bush White House's panic the untold
story of the 2008 financial crisis airs
tonight on HBO it's fascinating
fascinating really good whatever get a
sense of the real humanity behind what's
going on yeah all right Alex thanks so
much